thank you all for coming we're delighted
by this turnout this is a terrific
turnout I'm sure the largest we've had
in boston though i don't have data to
prove it and you have to be careful
about making claims like that in front
of a Carnegie Mellon audience but until
someone tells me otherwise it's the
biggest turnout we ever had in Boston
this panel which we'll get to in due
course is something I'm very excited
about and you'll see why these are
five-star faculty who not only are stars
in terms of the research and teaching
they do but they're tremendously
engaging they like each other which is
good they interact well together and
this stuff is phenomenal it truly is the
future and you'll see why Carnegie
Mellon is as great as it is so you know
that but sort of today's version is as
great as it is it's also particularly
fitting that we hold such a futuristic
pioneering path-breaking panel here in
Boston Boston has been declared the
number one research center in America by
none other than Atlantic magazine a
definitive source it's no doubt true and
it's no doubt true because of the many
one has to say so so universities that
exist here in the Boston area but it's
also true because of the very
significant population of Carnegie
Mellon alumni in the Boston area in fact
with 3,000 Carnegie Mellon alumni Boston
is fourth in terms of the number of our
graduates outside of Pittsburgh so you
are really very significant to us in in
many ways and I'm not joking when I say
that you are very much a reason why
Pittsburgh what has slipped why Boston
would be such an important
research and Technology Center one of
the ways we think about this is 3000 is
a big number to us it's that's so big
for a lot of universities we think of
Carnegie Mellon in carnegie mellon
people as having disproportionate impact
it's a great phrase and i think one
that's apt we're not a large University
but we have an impact we fight above our
weight that's one way someone let's put
it we are a striving scrappy place and
we have an impact bigger than our size
the this shows up in many ways so here
in Boston one of the here are two
examples because they like them because
they brackets so nicely Carnegie Mellon
what it's all about on the one hand the
world's largest car sharing service is
led by Scott Griffith the CEO Scott hit
that zipcar I'm talking about who is a
engineering graduate from Carnegie
Mellon in of 1981 the same time as you
probably know Boston Pops the famous
Boston Pops is led by Keith Locker a
graduate of our school of music of 1983
so there you are business and music
science and the arts technology and the
arts and it's happening here in Boston
as well and of course I could say the
same thing about every sector one might
want to look at the impact of Carnegie
Mellon around the world though is
something we're all so proud of not just
here in Boston pittsburgh has become and
continues to grow as a center for the
technology and knowledge economy and
something I'll say more about later at
the same time your universities become
global and very global in the last five
or ten years in addition to our campus
in Pittsburgh we now have campuses in
Silicon Valley in Doha in Qatar and in
Adelaide Australia and we have graduate
programs in
more than 14 countries and we're in
advanced discussions about creating
campuses in three more this is something
that is new for us something that's very
exciting and something that has really
expanded the Carnegie Mellon impact and
footprint in fact we think it's a major
reason why we were ranked number 20 by
The Times of London this is notable you
may know that in for the US News
rankings which ranks only American
universities were ranked 22nd but The
Times of London Rex's 20th in the world
you can reconcile them you can try some
kind of quantum effect that I even
figured out yet and again you know this
is reflective of our impact that is
bigger than our sides a couple of other
examples which not only again show our
impact but again the the two sides of
our brain how many universes can claim
that they had three of their people when
Nobel prizes in the last two years which
we did at the same time last month we
had seven alumni nominated for a Tony
Awards three Nobel Prizes seven
nominations we probably won't get seven
awards but we'll get some how many
universities can say that and that is
Carnegie Mellon I'm talking about alumni
here by the way not current faculty or
current students these are all alumni
thought the Nobel Prize winners and the
Tony Award nominees Carnegie Mellon has
changed in a lot of ways I know some of
you have not been back in a long time
because I asked you shame on you come
back to Pittsburgh bring your spouse to
show him or her the wonderful campus
that you graduated from and rediscover
Carnegie Mellon and Pittsburgh in the
process and you'll see great changes its
and it's great to see both on campus and
in the city but one thing I
you always to keep in mind is as much as
we've changed and as much as we will
continue to change or Carnegie Mellon
after all we're still based on the same
core values that shape the university
that you attended no matter when you
attended or that you will attend we have
a lot of accepted freshman a new
freshman in the audience tonight the
same core values hard work yes future
freshman new freshman you will work like
dogs when you come to Carnegie Mellon
it's true hard work which we see as a
virtue my heart is in the work is our
slogan problem solving interdisciplinary
collaboration and teamwork and
innovation that's who that's what
Carnegie Mellon has been a bit about for
at least 60 years in arguably 110 years
that has not changed and I can guarantee
you won't change because those are the
values of which our success has been
built tonight our focus is on isn't on
an aspect of what is the title we use
human in artificial intelligence or
human versus artificial intelligence
this is part of a broader initiative the
Carnegie Mellon that we call brain mind
and learning and I'll say more about it
later but you'll be hearing much more
about it from the panel and much better
than I can ever talk about it but that's
only one there are two other major
initiatives I want you to know about one
is energy in the environment something
that thankfully virtually every major
research university in the country is
working on and Carnegie Mellon is no
exception we already have great
strengths in this but we want to build
on those and in particular focus
Carnegie Mellon on the major challenge
of the transition from what is now a
fossil fuel based economy to what will
replace it in the future this is going
to be a very hard transition it's going
to take a very long time several decades
but it's essential and it's going to
happen one
we're another it's going to happen
Carnegie Mellon has a great deal to
contribute in technology in science in
management and in policy and the great
cardigan on strength of course is we're
able to work across those domains
together you'll be hearing about in the
next year or so next several months the
launching of a new energy futures
Institute which will be focused on just
that the other area i want to mention is
Theta intensive computing or what we
call finally computational X the notion
being that this problem of dealing with
massive data sets in ur internet scale
data is so-called is one that cuts
across virtually every field it
certainly has become the dominant way or
a dominant mode for the way science is
done but it's also the case in business
and marketing in government for those
sort of governments sophisticated enough
to realize this where the age of massive
data sets is with us and the question is
what can you extract from it well this
is something that Carnegie Mellon is
extremely strong in and has been for
many years and we call a computational X
because we think x can be equal just
about anything and we've created already
major efforts in computational biology
computational finance our new thrusts in
physics is in cosmology and it's all
about computation we have a new effort
in computational social science with our
Hines College in the lead but with
computer science and others involved and
the list goes on but the same time we
want to be the place and will be the
place that takes the lead in designing
the next generation of computers and
software that one needs to do a proper
job of analyzing this data so brain mind
and learning energy and environment
computational X these are major thrusts
that we are
involved in this kind of activity is
indicative of a very vibrant University
the University that continues to move
forward leap forward a place that
attracts phenomenal people including new
freshmen and new freshmen
congratulations welcome almost I'll be
standing in front of you and your
families in mid August when you move in
and say welcome truly then we're
delighted to have you and it's a
privilege to be admitted to Carnegie
Mellon the numbers are remarkable
actually don t even frightening if
you're a member of our admissions office
we had more than 12 applicants for each
slot and the quality and credentials of
the students are really remarkable it's
no surprise that we have students with
perfect s80 scores and perfect straight
A's and all of that it is a little bit
disturbing that we have an awful lot of
students with perfect s80 scores in
straight A's who we reject it and more
and more in that category but all this
speaks of is the tremendous demand an
interest in Carnegie Mellon and the
wonderful students that we get one of
the reasons there is great interest in
Carnegie Mellon no doubt is because
students or lease their parents want
them to go to a place where they have a
good shot of getting a job when I
graduate and I think more and more
students are very sensitive to this
Carnegie Mellon is surely such a place
it's not for nothing that we were ranked
tenth by the wall street journal for a
good place by recruiters basically and
the most highly ranked private
university very interesting public
universities are ranked higher because
they're bigger and recruiters like to go
places where there are a lot of students
there aren't a lot of students at
Carnegie Mellon but the value that they
know they get the quality
enough to bring them there not only are
we attracting great people but
increasingly we're attracting great
companies to Pittsburgh just last month
I participate in the opening of a
pittsburgh office for lockheed martin
which is open open this office to work
on cyber security with Carnegie Mellon
if you followed then the paper the news
recently you know lockheed martin needs
a research center on cybersecurity and
we're glad they chose us to work with us
they're just the latest in quite an
impressive list of companies that set up
very significant centers in Pittsburgh
Google opened their engineering and
engineering center in Pittsburgh about
five years ago in a building we built on
the edge of campus called the
collaborative innovation center
specifically to attract technology
companies to open offices in Pittsburgh
Google is one of the first tenants
they've grown so fast and so much they
had to move out and now they occupy
office space in something called bakery
square which is the old Nabisco plant in
east liberty now in front of a lot of
audiences when I say that I get gasps as
in Google in east liberty maybe didn't
understand me because if you're
pittsburghers I know y'all I'm supposed
to say slipper T is the way you
pronounce the East Liberty it's a
remarkable thing it's a great thing and
we don't feel bad about Google moving
out because Disney moved in a Disney lab
yes joining Intel Apple and a Microsoft
lab in the collaborative innovation
center it's a tremendous story at the
same time we've been working to increase
the number of companies we start in fact
we've been so successful at this we're
now second in the country in terms of
the number of startups per dollar
sponsor research and all of this of
course contributes to the great progress
that pittsburgh has
aid we are very keen on continuing to
promote innovation and company creation
in Pittsburgh and everywhere for that
matter and I was delighted to announce
at commencement that jonathan kaplan one
of our alums who was the founder of flip
video camera if you're below 30 you know
what I'm talking about he said he became
very successful he created a fund i
announced that well that will be
strictly for the purpose of funding
startups by young alumni so if you
graduated within the last five years you
are eligible for this and all you got to
do is contact us it's called open field
entrepreneurship fund go to our web I
don't know if what's up on the web yet
but it will be just check this is just
one of many things we're doing to
promote Carnegie Mellon as a place for
innovation Jonathan's story is a great
one and Jonathan giving back is a great
story as well and one thing I want to
make sure I convey to you alumni and the
alumni participation in the University
by giving money but by participating in
events like this by coming back by
interacting with current students I hope
you met our Highland ambassadors where
are you hi line ambassadors all the way
in the back they should be up front
they're gorgeous the way young people
are and very exciting and full of energy
these are current students who have put
themselves sort of into the mix by
actively interacting with alumni in this
way our students love to interact with
alumni your support for that your
support for the university does not just
with money but with your own
participation this is what helps
universities be great now your money is
important there's no question about that
not just in terms of funds like the one
that jonathan kaplan set up but frankly
the the business model for universities
is very simple everything we do loses
money and the way we make up the loss is
through gifts from alumni it's that
simple that's why endowments and Annual
Giving are so important to universities
and why those universities with large
endowments do better than others with
smaller ones and that's why part of our
campaign is so focused on endowment I'll
come back to that and close with that in
a minute but first I want to acknowledge
some of the people alumni who are
involved with the University in
exceptional ways we have three trustees
here tonight and I want to acknowledge
their presence bill Ellis dick Hamilton
and Louis Steinbrenner all alumni all
trustees and they all traveled a long
way to be with us gentlemen if you don't
mind standing up we'd like to recognize
they even stick together you see in that
that makes me a little bit nervous when
my bosses are conferring like that I
want to acknowledge Kevin again for his
contributions to our Alumni Association
Board and all those have around the
country in the world who do the Boston
alumni group is very active and we're
delighted by that I want to acknowledge
the leadership who are with us tonight
Kevin again Myron Lewis Bruce Carol and
Jay Snyder and anybody else on the board
that I might have missed it he'd stand
up so we can recognize you leaders thank
you
rosemary
and and finally some of my colleagues
other than the faculty involved in the
panel traveled with me other leaders of
the University and I want to acknowledge
them john'll ahoskie the Dean of the
College of Humanities and Social
Sciences wife Mary Lou and Robbie Kossak
the vice president for University
Advancement colleagues would you stand
up so II hope to see you
our capital campaign is doing very well
we've raised well over seven hundred
million dollars but we have a goal of a
billion dollars we're sort of in the
home stretch we are committed to raising
286 million dollars in the next two
years and it's going to happen if our
alumni and our friends step up the way
they have in the first part of this
campaign and I know that we can count on
you we've been very fortunate that this
campaign has had exceptional leadership
ray lane who now is chairman of our
board of trustees and a managing partner
at Kleiner Perkins was the prior chair
of the campaign and now at Frank has
succeeded him ed is a vice president for
engineering at apple and he currently
chairs the campaign both our members of
the board of trustees I like to invite
your attention to this short video which
will say a little bit more about the
University in the campaign
at Carnegie Mellon University innovation
is part of our DNA we are defined by our
creative spark tireless work ethic and
commitment to problem solving we bring
multi-talented dream teams together like
no one else can we set the standard for
engineering education we helped
establish the field of artificial
intelligence we created the first
internet search engine we continue to
revolutionize business education and
train generations of artists composers
and actors at carnegie mellon students
are deeply involved in research we push
the envelope with new educational models
that anticipate emerging professions and
the changing world mentored by our
premier faculty students can explore and
combine disciplines in new ways we
produce students who think creatively
who are well grounded in their field and
more apt to leave they are architects of
change at every stage of our evolution
our innovations have been made possible
by philanthropy that prizes guts in
audacity that's why we're asking you to
join inspire innovation the campaign for
Carnegie Mellon University now is a
critical time for this campaign it is
something we all can work to achieve it
is something that will add a tremendous
amount to our endowment when you think
about what can I go do to help the world
position itself for the future there's
probably no better place to put your
time energy and ultimately money than
into universities because these are the
places that are educating students that
are doing the research they're really
shaped the world
by investing in the University today you
have an opportunity to accelerate that
you have an opportunity to take this and
put it on an even greater exponential
ramp for success and impact a major goal
of inspire innovation is to build our
endowment you can help us do this by
supporting any of the university's
priority areas your support through
scholarships fellowships and other
student life initiatives will enable us
to educate the best and the brightest
students you can help us retain
world-class faculty by supporting
endowed professorships and funds for
faculty start-up and research by
investing in annual giving programs
unrestricted funds and support for our
libraries you can help us sustain
breakthrough innovation finally
additional funding for new and renovated
facilities will renew the campus support
research and enhance student life the
world is stole the problems and Carnegie
Mellon is the ultimate innovative
problem-solving University we thrive on
that a harder the problem the more
important the problem the better
Carnegie Mellon response
you